and here we have rendy um senior ux
quantitative researcher he's going to
talk about solving the problems in front
of
you right thanks everyone for coming so
I'm Randy I'm going to be talk about
solving the problems in front of you um
so a couple details by myself I am a
quantiative ux researcher at Google I
know that is not a common job title not
very many companies have it the TDR is
that we are Quant ux researchers are
data people who want to understand
people we use data science methods
social science methods and to to look at
data look at what people do so that we
can understand what people want for
their products how they're using those
products and then hopefully we take that
information give it to engineers and
product people so that they can build
better products right um some and the
interesting part is because we are a
research organization we're out of data
science organization we tend to do
things that are a bit I suppose you
would want to say you need to collect
weird bits of data sometimes for example
if we have to build a if we need a
specific kind of survey collection data
system if we can't sweet talk an
engineer to like build the thing for us
we wind up building it ourselves so we
have a mix of guys who do survey stuff
serious like survey research from
Academia and we have data scientists
folk who are like maintaining and like
engineering pipelines for our data
collection processes and there's a
really big mix of skills in our group
right
so prior to Google I spent 10 years
doing startups around New York City the
relevant part is that I was a data
person of some sort your analyst or
engineer back then data Sciences wasn't
a title yet and the size of the
companies were tiny it's like 2500
bigest was about 120 150 um this will be
slightly relevant as we go along with
the talk but anyways today I want to
think I want you to ask ask you guys to
think about some big problems You'
worked on right like you know we need a
single source of Truth for data
got we want you know we need a data
model for collecting some stuff someone
please build me a data warehouse build a
reporting system right just think about
what you feel about when you embarked or
finish one of these projects right I
don't know how would you describe that
think about that I would call it painful
that's what comes to my head right slow
conflicting
requirements I'm not sure what I'm doing
when i'm doing these projects there's
obviously too much choice and I'm
probably the nicest thing I could say
was that mistakes were made and overcome
right like that's how I feel when I'm
doing these
things big projects are hard all right
and we tend to make them harder for
ourselves all right so Donal K uh famous
uh you know data like not data scientist
computer scientist who in the 70s before
a couple years before he inflicted Tech
on all of grad students around the world
he wrote this paper saying premature
optimization is the RO of all evil it's
actually actually the paper is
structured programming with go-to
statements back in the 70s but I dug it
out just you know this is a very famous
adage amongst programmers and people who
work with computers that premature
optimization is bad but then like the
last line like the part that's not after
I highlight there yet we should not pass
up our opportunities for that critical
3% just kind of like just throws it out
there and then like doesn't tell you
pretty much how I identify this 3% right
it's just like there there's like gold
here we shouldn't do the bad stuff but
we should do like it's hard right so
when we think about optimization yes
there's a technical term for optimizing
and it has you know a lot of things
going on with it but in the common usage
of it right we have it's about like
making stuff like better as an a making
an existing thing go faster making the
existing thing more efficient right it's
not about you don't really think about
optimizing as when I'm Dreaming up
something to build I'm op optimizing
that's not something that we do right
it's but optimizing happens at the start
of design right think about all the
times you're envisioning how something
works you're going from a not working
state right where something has infinite
runtime because it's never working and
you're going to a finite runtime working
state right that is some form of
optimization right you can imagine that
picking the right algorithm matters
right you know that I probably shouldn't
be using bubble s for whatever it is I'm
doing right that is the designs that
decision to make sure that you don't use
that you're not even going to try bubble
SW you know it's that right but that's a
design decision that's an optimization
right there right so optimization is
both required right and yet we're warned
not to do it it's not you can't just say
don't optimize because then you're going
to be using bubbles for all the place
and you know that's bad but where do you
draw this line right like the art is to
know when to stop optimizing it's not
that you can't you shouldn't do it
because you obviously have to do it just
where did we stop right so now there's a
lot of reasons to do optimization up
front I'm sure you can sympathize with
this we've all been ban like hit the bad
systems right like the back end that's
like five databases that you know been
glued together the repurpose database
field right the name has not changed but
it's now like you know that integer is
now a bit field I know I'm an engineer
in my head that I'm cursing right now
because he did that to me and my seatel
has bitwise operators because of him
uh you know that Json field in the
database that has like 8 megabytes of
text in it
now those people who have we just use
excels for that right and now what are
you going to do right we don't want to
build the next system that everyone
laughs at right I don't want to but if I
build a system I'm going to bet money
that 10 years down the road someone's
either going to laugh at it or want to
burn it to like the ground right we
don't want to be that person it's kind
of just part of how we want to be
respected as
practitioners uh we are supposed to
learn from others right there are any
topic you can think of someone's
probably thought about it built it wrote
something about it somewhere you know in
Academia a million blog posts vendors
would love to tell you how they're
solving the problem right the thing is
that like when I'm doing this I'm not an
expert on this like we're in the
Microsoft building right now I work at
Google I'm pretty sure like in one of
these buildings the world expert the
person who wrote The Textbook on
whatever problem it is that I'm working
on is somewhere here I don't know where
that person is I don't know who that
person is in theory I should find them
and ask them about my really simple data
warehouse project and they would
probably be happy to help but yet I
would feel really bad about wasting
their time on my really simple thing
right so but I'm supposed to do this as
a you know good practitioner this is
like supposed to be I'm supposed to
learn from the mistakes of others right
so and then fixing the mistakes that I
do make seems really hard really
expensive right like I've got to admit
that I screwed up somewhere right if I
you know made a data warehouse and the
performance is one query per minute
that's probably bad I'm going to have to
someone's going to complain about that
everyone who depends on my really slow
data warehouse their all their work is
going to get thrown away if I throw away
my data warehouse design probably right
there's a lot of waste of time and
resources all the and then fixing it
will take even more resources to fix
hopefully and there's no guarantee that
the fix will actually work right like if
I designed a really bad system do you
trust me to build another system that's
better than the one I just St that's
that like I don't know right there's no
guarantees and most importantly why we
why do we optimize early on it's because
we feel really really smart when we do
right right like past me usually just
gives me problems right like I like when
the rare occasion when past me does
something really well I feel really
really good about that and it only
happened maybe once or twice in my
entire life but I still remember that
right so this is probably why right like
you know the one time that passed me and
gave me that good data warehouse I'm
going to like them okay so anyways an
example is just we have something
concrete to talk about it's like okay
imagine we're building a big old data
warehouse right business wants that
single sorts of truth that emoji is
doing a lot of lifting right now um
we've got a production database of some
sort there's vendors that are giving us
nightly csvs because of course they are
um right and there's FP server in there
right like yeah um we got a lot of logs
in this like could you cluster here the
formats
vary for reasons undisclosed right and
then like you know a couple Executives
have some very important Excel
files slal V2 right okay so I'm sure all
of you immediately have opinions and
options right that you're thinking about
what are we what are we going to do with
this situation right like do we keep
using to do do we do we go to the cloud
and go one of the various vendors in
there do we just buy a really really big
database and just like ignore all the
other things going on right like and
then you're thinking about like how do I
move data around like what what's going
on with the ETL do I need dags you know
do I need availability right yes no I
don't know like what performance do I
actually need right all these questions
are going around in your head and they
all have Solutions but then they they
raise more questions they raise more
constraints there just it's just so much
going on right so so you actually bu
what's going on and then you know you
ask anyone it's like it depends right
that's the internet answer to anything
it's like well you have a complex
problem it depends right like what is it
that you like it just goes right back
right like what is the design that I
need for my unique situation no one will
be able to tell you that and that's it
you just left there trying to think
right it like this answer is great for
for talks it's great for putting on
things on the internet but it doesn't
work for you right so what do you do you
have to launch something something right
so like all right I got to design
something and I still looked up like
system design process and then I don't I
don't understand any of this like how do
you design a system is like itself the
whole design project here apparently um
right like there are stages some more
some are cyclical and some are linear I
don't some have flowcharts going all
sorts of directions I don't know what's
going on so you're like all right well I
got to design something that's be you
know very rational about this right get
get requirements look at my options
eliminate the ones that don't work right
the design you know you prove that thing
works make a prototype and then like we
build the thing right it's like
reasonable doesn't seem crazy and then
I've been talking about this in a
generic thing since right but like you
know if you work in Enterprise if you
work in a company that's let's say more
than 500 people essentially all this is
like hard there's a hard mod to it right
you got more people which means more
constraints more stakeholders more
meetings more requirements coming out of
meetings you got more approvals because
people want to sign off on things right
you got a lot more bike sheds to paint
right you there's a lot more politics
involved money you can think that you
know a giant mega cor resources you got
more resources this is supposed to be a
good thing but now you have more options
right like you you like as a startup you
don't have the budget to buy that $1
million database well at a large large
large company you actually have an
option you have to sit down and think
should we actually buy this extremely
expensive thing right you have to
consider building versus buying in the
sense that well we actually have really
smart Engineers do I want to devote all
their salary and time to building a
custom system for our own needs versus
buying something off the shelf it
becomes like a decision that you can
make and therefore you have to at least
consider it right it just makes things
worse it doesn't make like resources
don't really make things better right
so I can't figure out Le inside of my
head where the line is between designing
right all the stuff we were talking
about and overdesigning which is still
the same stuff that we were talking
about right you've been rational about
it like we you know none of the things
that the steps we've laid out the things
we've concerned we're trying to address
are are like something you would flag as
okay we just skip this step doesn't seem
reasonable to say that about any of the
things we're doing right you've got so
sit down you have like tables you have
notes you've got all sorts of things
trying to compare a versus B versus C
right you're reading papers you're
talking to people you're asking people
what's going on you're sketching out
things and then it all seems like you're
just doing design work right but then 3
weeks have kind of
passed stand
up like what progress are you going well
I've read this book I've got five more
books here and don't look at my Amazon
because I got more coming like it's
getting a little awkward right so and
then like you've got the what if
questions like the big question what if
you know we scale right we go web scale
you know people old enough to get that
joke um what if you know it's not fast
enough for that should someone's going
to ask are we going to move to the cloud
and you're going to have to have an
answer for them right and then like okay
well imagine if we got this if we
somehow did all this work got a perfect
data warehouse working what are the
future U cases right I have can now
imagine like a business unit that
doesn't exist and what they're going to
do with my thing
like right so and you're also thinking
about like what's going on with the
schema right like all right I got tables
everywhere I got to like manage all the
keys bouncing around I've got like you
know figuring out what do I bring over
from the Legacy stuff and what's
redundant how do I do like do I
precompute aggregations or not like
there are opinions about cubes right
like schema changes like are we going to
allow them not allow them do we care is
it no SQL SQL how are we going to do
that there's a lot of things going on
with partitioning that that I don't even
understand right and I'm sure someone
here in this building does right so you
know what are the signs that you're
starting to optimize a little bit too
early right like you've got too many
options and you start hit this point
where you're like I can't even tell a
like these all look good enough and I
don't know anymore and you just hit that
wall and you you you start realizing
it's like wait I'm I'm going in a circle
here I've like read 10 more close about
this thing and I'm still coming to the
same decision that these two things are
similar enough what do I do right um
you're accounting for situations that
are become increasingly unlikely like
yeah you know if I'm doing like a
personal web server project I'm probably
not going to get to the point where I
have 20 million visitors a day that's
probably not likely but if I'm planning
for that I'm probably over overdesigning
right and another sign is like your core
design like the way the architecture is
kind of hanging onto itself it hasn't
changed very much I'm just like
evaluating should I swap this little
thingy in should I just add a load
balancer here what happens if I you know
mix around with the network a little bit
like that probably shouldn't matter at
the design case right you kind of
realize like oh things are starting to
look like a waterfall here right um this
was taken out of zoo I found it in my
archives and it just happened to have a
tiger in there I was like oh this is
perfect perfect photo for this thing
right but I'm proposing that you know
know you guys collectively know of
another extreme of Designing right like
hackathons now no now like I'm going to
there's a slide here don't ever ever
ever production database in a hackathon
probably not a good idea you will get
exactly what you pay for in that
situation but if you're going to try
tell me about it so I can learn from it
right so hackathons we can learn from
the notion of hackathon I'm not saying
we designed to a hackathon but I'm
saying we can learn Le about how to run
things with one right so you know think
about half there's tight enforced
deadlines right there's time pressure a
huge amount of time pressure and it
forces you to shove a lot of research in
mind off of your plate right like I I
don't have I have five days to do this
thing or I have one day to do this thing
I can only read so much because I have
to write code so you you just pay that
cost later you're like I'm going to slap
down something and hope that it works
right you start you stop thinking you
implement and the deadline is completely
arbitrary and it's not scaled to the
difficulty of the project right like
think about it like a normal deadline
you're like oh it'll take me X number
days to do this thing you make an
estimate it's scaled to how hard you
think it is like hackathons don't care
right they're like you got a week
whatever you get you get right no matter
like whether it's like flying a rockets
in a moon or like building a website you
got a week right this is actually a good
thing like because it is a hard time box
right there are you know effective these
zero expectations right like you know
you're going to cut Corners right like
you've seen haon projects where like the
the final thing like the backend data is
like all hand tight that's like over my
desperately because they don't have time
to do the ml part of it right like yeah
Corners are being cut there's no elegant
designs in there performance
expectations are practically zero right
you don't expect the scale cuz you're
going to throw this code away anyway
right so you know you want like it's
okay to throw away the code in this
situation right you keep the knowledge
of building the code you don't have to
like worry about you know a lot of
details and then you can find the
problem that you didn't think about
right like all the times a remember
you're like implementing something and
you're like oh I I need this abstraction
I didn't think about I like 20 more
libraries oh this Linux distribution is
just not working for me not stuff you
think about but it gets in your way
right but like think about how much
better you you are at the next project
because you hit all these Road Ms in
this will throw away P
right and it's okay if it works and it's
okay if it fails right the stakes are
low so people don't care about your
hackathon project and you're going to
learn something so what I'm saying is
like you should solve the problems in
front of you when you're kind of doing
these large scary projects right kind of
like as if you were in a hackathon
because you're only solving the
immediate problems right I need a
database right now I'm going to go grab
the the most easy to install one off the
shelf and plop it down I'm going to get
a web server I'm just going to get the
most bog standard thing and slap it down
and connect my two things and hopefully
I have web app going right like as the
complexity comes you're solving it
you're not really thinking that far
ahead right you are time boxing your
exploration right the making failure
viable means that yeah if I didn't
consider this use case that's okay it'll
fail but that's fine the naive solution
kind of works right um and you you know
you're handling the clear requirements
right it just cuts down on those like
choices right like no one at a hackathon
is going to go byy aund million database
like the purchasing process would go
beyond the week anyway right so it just
makes it easier right you're just
throwing things away until you get to
something that kind of works right and
then you should also handle the obvious
follow-ups right like okay fine we have
a data warehouse now it is functioning
kind of as in intended I know that
people are going to use it for just one
use case that we haven't programmed in
yet because they keep asking us right so
like the scope is not just exactly what
people tell you that you wanted to do
it's just okay a little bit beyond that
to the things that are you anticipate
are really really going to happen right
it's just a way to hint at yourself that
I should leave some flexibility I
shouldn't just build exactly two new
plans there's got to be a little bit of
room there because this thing will grow
and then you should think about proc
processes as functions for a lot of
these design things right you should
chunk your designing just like you would
chunk your code right it's like you
should have separation of concerns so
that hey X passes something to B if you
can make it so that there's some
abstraction that you can just pass
things along without thinking about it
then your design is that much more
flexible if you if one piece if that
database piece doesn't work you can rip
the data base piece out put some other
database piece in that kind of has the
same interface
and expect it to kind of work right like
having everything glued together in a
monolith is probably a bad
idea and then you should expect to
rebuild things right like the throw away
hackathon code well you
know building something the second time
around usually is so much better than
the than the first time some people I
know they actually actively throw like
when they when they plan on building a
project they will think about building
it and then just automatically throwing
away the first one it's like writing a
paper the first strap is always garbage
right you the the a lot of writers they
say that the value of writing comes in
in the rewrite of that first STP because
you get all your ideas down you finally
see the structure of it but now you can
kind of like take a knife to it rip out
all the extraneous parts put in
emphasize all the good parts
right and so you also have to remember
that results are grown over time I like
to pick on this if you go to any cloud
provider I work at Google Cloud so I get
to pick on Google Cloud um and you look
up their architecture for building a
website you'll get something like this
something extremely complex I know AWS
has an extremely complex one I'm pretty
sure Azure has one also right if you
think about it a web server the minimum
you need is one machine connected to the
internet just running Apache right basic
install but then why is it that there's
a app engine on here why is there CDN
and in cloud and blob storage why is
there cash going on why is there logging
going on all these were bolted on for
specific use cases but I'm pretty sure
that like they weren't added on just
because it was specified in some best
practice thing they serve our purpose
right like I need logging because I want
something if I don't care about that
aspect of logging if I don't care about
you know metrics or or understanding
bugs or whatever if I just want my
website to be on there and I don't care
about anything else then logging doesn't
need to be on there right so it's okay
to like re refactor architectures
because like list architecture didn't
grow up over like you know
overnight then I'm going to ask you to
have faith in your future self just like
how past me gives present me all sorts
of problems you're going to be giving
future you problems but you should have
faith in that you're able to solve it
think about all the clever hacks that
you've done with with databases right
like oh you found a clever way to
squeeze out that much extra information
information um with like you know using
uniques or a fancy little joint or some
fancy little logic so that you can get
that answer for like analytics that you
normally would not expect out of your
existing database right like that will
happen to your system you just have to
have faith that you can solve that
problem when it becomes concrete and you
can do it and that's it for my talk you
can find me on these places I write a
newsletter where every week I talk about
write about um mundan data science
topics like this and yeah if you guys
have comments want to share stories
about horrible things I more than happy
to talk about them thank you
[Applause]
guys yeah I just love the trench book
part thank
you MH thank you so much Randy all right
thank you guys and if if you guys have
any questions please raise your hand and
then you ask
question yeah do you take your own
advice I try but then like my advice is
like to YOLO it
essentially and so I do try but I like
the hard part is like remembering to try
right like I forget like cuz it's so
easy to just fall into the over design
phase right so but like there's some
there's a point where internally I'm
like all right I'm getting frustrated at
this I I need to just do it and then uh
you know set an artificial deadline to
myself and just do it that helps or at
least for
me yeah all the voices coming into this
there's The Perennial
one yeah yeah do you find like anything
in particular drives that like desire
over design when you're like falling
into that H I think it's because all of
us as data people have really good
imaginations we we see a lot of crazy
things happening on the world for
example if we if I tell you that I'm
going to put a text box on the internet
and put it to a database you're you're
all imagining horrible stories right now
I'm pretty sure about that right like
right we've seen it and so because of
that we want to we want to stop it like
we want to put validation in there we
want to make sure like our database
doesn't explode because someone puts
like a million btes into a a thing yeah
so that's why we over like but it's it's
it's hard for us to like know when to
stop right because it's just like we
imagine all the scenarios they all seem
extremely common because we've seen
examples of them and that throws us into
a bias where it's like wait I probably
don't care if this database Falls over
because it's only you know a toy project
I should just let that go it's it's okay
right and that's really hard to tell
someone who's like likes to cross all
the T not all the eyes
so anyone
else all right thank you
guys